مساء الخير تكلفه الفرصه المدينه تعبير
اقتصادي مهم جدا فهمه كما تخلفه من
الاقتصاد بصفه عامه و كمعيار لتقييم
القرارات واتخاذ القرارات ايضا سواء في
مجال الاستثمار او في الحياه على اساس
علمي المقصود بكلمه الكويتيون تقصد او
تكلفه الفرصه او تكلفه الفرصه البديله او
التكلفه البديله وان اي فرد اي شرك اي
حكومه لما تستقر على خيار بيقوم بالضروره
تركت خيارات اخرى الخيارات الاخرى دي هي
اللي بيسموها تكلفه الفرصه بمعنى بسيط جدا
لو انه فرد من الافراد انسان قرر انه بعد
الدراسه الكليه انه هي ارض سنتين لدراسه
دراسات عليا ماجستير مثلا تكلفه الماجستير
مشكله بس المصاريف او الرسوم التي دفع على
الجامعه والانتقالات والكتب والدروس
التكلفه الظاهره لكن التكلفه الكليه
والشامله هي الخسائر اللي هذا الشخص عليه
ان يتحمل ها نتيجه انه مضطر العدم انه
ياخذ فرصه عاما او انه اشتغل او الوظيفه
اللي ماخذها علشان يتفرغ للدراسه فلما
بيحس ب التكلفه
الاوسط بيقول انا دافعت فلوس في الماجستير
ده مبلغ بهذا القدر لكن كمان جزء من
التكلفه او التكلفه الكليه بتشمل الخسائر
التي لم تتحقق لاننا قررت ان اترك الوظيفه
التي كان يمكن ان احصل عليها وبالتالي تدر
على
عدم اخذت للوظيفه هو تكلفه الفرصه البديله
الكلام ده بينطبق على كذلك الشركات الشركه
عندها مبلغ معين مخصصات معينه عشان
تستقبلها اذا استثمرت ها في المشروع ده
صعبه تستثمرها في مشروع اخر وكذلك
الحكومات فكره الفرصه البديله نابعه من
فكره جوهريه جدا
اللي مفهوم علم الاقتصاد علم الاقتصاد
بيسموه تشمل تايمز او العلم الكريم ليس
لانه على المسار
كما يتصور الناس ولكن لانه يبحث او هو
فكرته كلها قائمه في البحث عن خيارات
نتيجه النظره علم الاقتصاد موجود لان فيه
نظر فيه نظر في الموارد في نظره في الوقت
في نظره في الجثت وعلشان في مضره يبقى
لازم نبحث افضل الاختيارات وعشان كان
بيقولوا علم الاقتصاد وعلم الاختيارات
وعشان كده بيكون فيه دائما خلاف ما بين
الاقتصاديين كل واحد شايف الصح وفقا ل
دراسات جدوى ودراسه الفرص المتعدده وفقا
لمبدا الفرنسي البديله الحاجه الوحيده
اللي ما فيش فيها نظرا الى رغبات الانسان
واحلام فيه مفتوحه ولكن على ارض الواقع لم
عاوزه هي نفس الشيء هو لازم يختار واللي
اختاروا معناه انه يترك في مقابله
اختيارات اخرى المالكي ان تطبق الكلام دا
على مستوى الحكومات نشوف مثلا انه اي قرار
بتقدر الحكومه مثلا القطار السريع ان
الحكومه المغربيه سعت الى تنفيذه هناك عن
طريق شركه فرنسيه كما سمعت يعني او
المشروعات اللي بيعملها الامير محمد بن
سلمان زين اليوم في البحر الاحمر على
شواطئ البحر الاحمر او المشروعات القوميه
اللي بتم تقوم بها الحكومه المصريه من
الجدل على على على امنيه المشروعات يبقى
كيف جدا وفي اطار علمي لم ان يفهموا في
اطار تكلفه الفرصه البديله يعني ما يكونش
السؤال هل القطار السريع
الحكومه المغربيه شرعت في تنفيذ هو مفيد
ام لا قطعا هو مفيد لكن سؤال ال الادق
علميا هل كان الا فيه انا اعمل القطار ده
لا ينقل الناس من النقطه الف نقطه به وهذه
الفوائد بتكلفه 500 مليون دولار على سبيل
المثال امكان الافضل ان الخمسمائه مليون
دولار دول يتم توظيفهم في مشروع اخر على
سبيل المسائل انشاء عدد من المصانع اللي
تخدم قطاع معين او اللي الواردات او اللي
توصف على الكثير من المغاربه المتعطلين عن
العمل
في فرصه ودي فورس اذا اذا قررت تستثمر
الخمسمائه مليون دولار دول في القطار
السريع معناها انك لم تنشا مصانع معنا
هناك لم تطور التعليم معناها انه وهكذا
والسبب ان الحكومه عندهاش عدد غير متناهي
من المخصصات دائما عندهم مخصصات محدوده كل
الجدل الذي دار على اللي داير على
المشروعات القوميه في مصر وفي غيرها في
القلب من مفهوم الفرصه البديله مثلا
العاصمه الاداريه جيده ولا لا البنى
التحتيه التي يقوم بها المشروع الرئيس
السياسي مفيده ولا
مدينه الجلاله مدينه العالمين اه اه ال اي
مشروع في الحكومه ما يكونش سؤال علميا هل
هذا مفيد ابلغ قطع المفروض ان يوفر فرصه
عام او لانه كذا لكن السؤال الادق علميه
هل لو انه مثلا مدينه العالمين تكلف اي
رقم وليكن مائه مليون دولار السؤال الان
المد مليون دولار افضل في انشاء مدينه
العالمين ولا استثمر هم في مشروع اخر ممكن
ان يدرك كذا وكذا وكذا وكذا لقد ما ان
تكون هناك دراسات جدوى ودراسات الوديه
بتبحث الفرصه المحل الدراسه والفرص الاخرى
التي يمكن انفاق عليها نفس الاموال
وبالتالي بتشوف العائد من الفرصه والفرص
له الشكر والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
نعم